I feel very positive and optimistic
about being alive on our planet that is
called Earth it's nice that you reminded
us which one Quran well I've done some
research you have have you
what's research have you done oh Christ
I've took myself into a terrible corner
it's not any of the other infinite
planets that must exist yes yes unless
this is all a dream yeah hold on Andy
I'm sorry if this is all a dream then
almighty for falling out suddenly nude
like in all dreams do you have a lot of
anxiety dreams like that dreams where
you're naive dreams like that a lot
where I'm naked and everyone's laughing
at my naked body Kernan I think that
perhaps wasn't a dream is a Wednesday I
think dreams want to make a bit more
effort like my dreams it's just
basically stuff that could happen yeah
Oh mundane things just like being a
dream I'm just of driving somewhere or
sort of dealing with the complaint in
the tax office yeah those aren't good
dreams you want dreams with dragons and
you know fire-breathing animals you want
that kind of a dream right time to be
reversed the futuristic beings to come
in creatures made of nothing but like
giving your secrets right my dreams yes
and then we all sit down to a big pizza
that's all your dreams end Russell
we have to talk about real things
eventually so I want to yes we do I want
to ask for watching your show and I
really enjoy it good one Russell so
lovely yeah it seemed perfectly Pleasant
out there
your crew though I don't know if done
deliberately it's like a gay bar back
there
I'm not suggesting that their actual
homosexuals but like homosexuals would
enjoy fantasizing about sex with them
yes real muscular big man everywhere at
my request we have very good-looking
about my existence I think we should
have beautiful men working here I just
do what fellas the fella that put they
sound cable on me so that I could be
audible to the audience he was so
attractive when he was putting all the
wires on me I imagined what it would be
like if the two of us truly loved one
another I know that one
he's a dreamboat he is a dreamboat if
only he'd notice house I think he's
noticing now Russell you're from England
tell us about the London Olympics we're
all wondering what's gonna happen can
you give us a heads oh my goodness look
at that
thank God you off I can do that too
you're a mess i limber that you can't do
this in an office chair very well my god
what goes on in your booth never mind
him now
I will take you to freedom
[Laughter]
so tell me old chum chum for life the
London Olympics this is something we
should be excited about here in America
how are you people going to do with the
Olympics are you I think around a little
pressure yes because when China did the
Olympics they really were clearly able
to demonstrate in the opening ceremony
we can make all of these people do the
exact same thing at once don't you think
and a war with us it was incredible they
had hundreds of thousands of people
doing everything on the slightest accent
I'm a bit us three couldn't do one thing
simultaneously believe it is as simple
as to sip from a mug let's try do it so
you think do you think London's gonna be
able to rise to the challenge no way
because like China they did such a great
job we're too clumsy we're too
self-effacing and as you know with the
English the politeness masks deep sexual
deviance
everyone did it's right there in the
photos guy what a pleasure to meet you
charmed I'm sure
so you think this is all gonna muck up
the Olympics for London you think it's
gonna make a mess of it I believe I love
England everything I'm from there but
just something that involves
organisation it's gonna be right
balls-up things are gonna catch fire
people will be tripping over things then
it'll start raining in the Queen will do
a fart
[Laughter]